[موسيقى]
بدل مسرح
بشكل جميل
ومتفاوت في حسب
الانظمه وحسب الدول وحسب مساحه الحريه
المتاحه لكل بلد
ووصل الى مهرجانات ووصل الى احتفالات ووصل
الى مركز يليق به كمسرح عالمي
ودخل العالميه وشارك في العديد من
المهرجانات
[موسيقى]
جايحه الكورونا وما اصاب الناس من بقاء في
البيوت والى اخره
تراجع المسرح تراجع كثيرا
لدرجه اصبح فيه شبه انعدام في غالب الدول
هذا التراجع هو وقتي مؤقت فقط حلم انتهت
هذه الجائحه عاده الحركه المسرحيه في بعض
الدول
ولكن في بعض الدول الاخرى تاخرت ونحن ممن
تاخر مسرحنا
[موسيقى]
هناك تراجع كبير على مستوى دول مجلس
التعاون على مستوى وطننا العربي هذا
التراجع
شمل مسائل عديده من ضمن هذه المسائل مشاكل
طرات على المسرح تعرض فيها المسرح
لانتكاسه كبيره
المسرح بطبيعته
حريه فكر ابداع متى ما تقيد واصبح يفرض
عليه بشكل مقيد لحريته فقد المسرح
اريقه وهجاه وفقد
تعاطيه مع القضايا الملحه للناس وللجمهور